القدس تنضم الينا مراسلات ليلى عوده ليلى
اهلا بك بدايه عن هذا الاتفاق ماذا عن
الشروط التي يمكن ان تتوفر في الفلسطينيين
للذهاب الى كاس العالم في قطر
مساء الخير حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتضح الصوره
ما ورد حتى الان وفقا لوسائل اعلام ما
قطريه بان الدوحه اشترطت على الاسرائيليين
للموافقه على الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل اليه
هو اكده رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه الاكيد
همم عندما قال بان هناك اتفاقا ثم توصل
اليه بعد عمل دؤوب مع الدوحه من اجل
السماح بقضيتين اعتبرهما رئيسيتين في
العلاقه لربما مع قطر او في الفتره التي
نتحدث عنها فتره مونديال كاس العالم الا
وهي فتح مكتب دبلوماسي مؤقت من اجل تسير
امور الاسرائيليين وتحديدا من المشجعين
واللاعبين في هذا المونديال خلال تلك
الفتره داخل قطر وايضا مساله تسير رحلات
مباشره من مطار بنغاريا وفي حتى الدوحه
لذلك هذه القضيه همم بدات قطر بوضع اشت
قطعتها كما تم ذكرها كما قلت عبر وسائل
الاعلام قطريه السماح لثمانيه الاف فلسطين
بالسفر الى قطر لا نعلم ان كان هناك هذا
الاشتراك سيتضمن على سبيل المثال
الفلسطينيين من غزه من الضفه ممن لا يسمح
لهم اصلا بالدخول الى القدس وتل ابيب من
اجل الى مطار روبنغاريا وهو المطار الذي
سيسير هذه الرحلات من خلال كما ك- قالت
الدوحه شركات طيران فقط محدده سينما سيتم
اختيارها وتعدد التصاريح التحليق والدخول
الى همم قطر الدفاع عن الحال هويه عن
فلسطين الذي سيسمح له بالمشاركه لما توضح
بعد هذه الاشتراكات ولكن الثمانيه الاف
يبدوا ان قطر تعمد وضع هذا العدد وهناك
ايضا نشرت اساسي
متعلق بالهدوء في كل من قطاع غزه والقدس
من يدفع هذه
التذاكر لانها مريضات الثمن همم لكن همم
هذا التساؤل جانبي سنطرح تساؤل اخر ليله
حول الاعلام الاسرائيلي منذ عده اشهر رشحت
معلومات ونقلتها قناه اي 24 الاسرائيليه
والتي تقول كانت ترجح الاعلان عن هذه
الاتفاقيه او فتح مكتب دبلوماسي بين
البلدين لكن قطر تراجعت عن همم هذا
الاتفاق عندما اراد الاسرائيليون للاعلان
عنه ما حقيقه ما يقوله الاسرائيليون بانها
مقدمه لتطبيع قطريا اسرائيلي
هناك محاوله عبر وسعر اعلام الاسرائيليه
لتسويق ذلك على انه هو اول الخطوات نحو
التطبيع والا كيف ستسير رحلات مباشره
ستدخل الاجواء القطريه من مطار بن غورن
وحتى الدوحه هناك محاوله لتسويق هذه
القضيه اسرائيليه على انها ليونه قطريه
ومحاوله لاستغلال هذه المباريات وهذا
المونديال من اجل تمرير هذه القضيه في قطر
يدركون هذه القضيه لذلك هناك تاكيدات
ومحاولات قطريه
لتفيد المحاولات الاسرائيليه والتاكيد من
قبل قطر بانها مضطر لهذه القضيه لانها
تحاول تسيير وتمرير اجواء هذا المونديال
ولكن نعلم بان قطر مدركه منذ اللحظه
الاولى ل- قبولها
بالقبول فيها باستضافه كاس العالم بانها
ستقوم بها هكذا خطوه ستستضيف الاسرائيليين
كما اي فريق دولي اخر ستستضيف المشجعين
الاسرائيليين كذلك
وصفه للشروط التي تستضيف بها اي مشجع
اجنبي اخر لذلك قطر مدرك هذه القضيه الى
اي حد سيتم لتسويق هذه الزياده وتيره هذه
القضيه اسرائيليا وحتى خليجيا الدول التي
تنتظر هذه القضيه لربما وكانت هناك
محاولات
حتى على المستوى الخليجي الاخر سنرى هذه
القضيه ولكن هناك تناقض ما بين محاوله
تفنيد قطر هذه القضيه بانها تطبيع محاوله
تكريس ذلك شكرا لك ليلى عوده
مباشره من